EVERYONE IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCE AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING HEARING HERE IN. THE
STREET BUILDING OUR FIRST
EDUCATION- MEETING HERE I ASK
ALL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE OF
BE PRESENT IN ROOM TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED SO WE CAN ESTABLISH OUR
QUORUM AND BEGIN THE HEARING. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE HEARING ROOM TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW I WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 877-226-8163 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN THREE SIX
TWO EIGHT THREE THREE FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND OR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN. ZERO FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. PRESS IS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THERE CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU
WILL BE ON MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US
TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MEET
THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONYOVER THE PHONE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN INDIA INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WE HAVE SIX BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA TO BILLS ARE ON CONSENT
THE BILLS ON CONSENT OUR ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB TEN SIXTEEN. ITEM
NUMBER FOUR SB TEN EIGHTY ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SB TWELVE NINETY
NINE HAS BEEN PULLED FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND WILL BE
HEARD TODAY. BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION OVER I GUESS THAT
WAS A QUORUM BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE ONE SO WE'RE GOING TO START
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE I THANK YOU
SENATOR PORTANTINO FOR BEING ON
TIME AND READY TO GO. WE'RE
GONNA START WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE WHICH IS SB. NINE
FORTY ONE. BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU ARE MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AND THANK YOU FOR I
BELIEVE IT'S TEN SIXTEEN ON
CENTER. STREET NOT QUITE
WELCOME. THE MORNING- AND I ALSO
WHEN DR PAN IS HERE ONE OF
THINKING HE WAS WILLING READY
AND ABLE TO TESTIFY ON MY BEHALF
BUT I MADE IT. I WANT TO THANK
HIM- SO I'M PRESENTING SP NINE
FOUR ONE WHICH ADDRESSES- SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT HAVE
BEEN- EXACERBATED THROUGH THE-
THROUGH COVERT. WITH A SHORTAGE
OF TEACHERS I IN PARTICULAR IN
STEM CLASSES AND DUAL LANGUAGE
IMMERSION PROGRAMS- SOME
SCHOOLS. STRUGGLE TO FIND-
TEACHERS AND HAD TO CANCEL
CLASSES WHICH DISRUPTED THE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT OF THE
PARENTS OF TWO KILLER. I IN THE
DUAL LANGUAGE CLASSES SO.
STUDENTS HAVE FACED
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES IN THIS
RUCTIONS AS WE KNOW SO WHEN THE
NOT COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC
STARTED. CALIFORNIA WAS ALREADY
EXPERIENCING A DECLINING NUMBER
OF TEACHERS IN THE 200-017-2000
EIGHTEEN SCHOOL YEAR. 80% OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS REPORTED
SHORTAGES. OF QUALIFIED
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS. SHORTAGES
ARE PARTICULARLY PRONOUNCED IN
RURAL AREAS COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
AND LOW SO KIDS SOCIOECONOMIC.
FOR THE CONSEQUENCES OF SUB
STANDARD LEARNING OUTCOMES ARE
LIKELY TO REVERBERATE. THROUGH
FUTURE EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT.
AND ECONOMIC PROSPECTS. A RECENT
REPORT BY THE LEARNING POLICY
INSTITUTE FOUND THAT. THE MOST
PRONOUNCED SHORTAGES INCLUDED.
TEACHERS FOR MATHS SCIENCE AND
BILINGUAL EDUCATION. THIS IS
FORCING SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
CANCEL CLASSES OR SEEK EMERGENCY
EMERGENCY CREDENTIALED TEACHERS
WHICH FRANKLY NO ONE. WANTS TO
SEE. ON ALTERNATIVE. THE CLASS
CANCELLATIONS ARE EMERGENCY
CREDENTIALS IS TO ALLOW
INTERDISTRICT COLLABORATIONS.
WHERE STUDENTS CAN PARTICIPATE
IN ANOTHER DISTRICTS CLASS.
WITHOUT HAVING TO UNROLL THEM.
FROM THAT CURRENT DISTRICT. THE
PRONOUNCE YOUR TO OF STEMMING A
LANGUAGE AND TEACHERS. MAY
SICKNESS TO FIND TO. AND
ALLOWING DISTRICTS TO
COLLABORATE- SEEMS LIKE A
LOGICAL STEP. SOME FOLKS HAVE
SAID WEISS IS NECESSARY BECAUSE
IN ORDER FIRST STUDENTS TO BE
RELEASED FROM SCHOOL SIR
SOMETIMES CAN BE A BURDENSOME
PROCESS HAVING TO GO THROUGH
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
HAVING TO DO. A FULL TIME
RELEASED THIS LET'S DISTRICTS
COLLABORATE SO TODAY I HAVE WITH
ME- DIANA BOO FROM THE ACCESS
WHO'S GOING TO TESTIFY AND J'MON
MOORE WHO IS A PARENT IN THE
PASADENA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
THAT WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE WHEN APPROPRIATE.
THE CENTER PORTANTINO AND TO OUR
TWO WITNESSES WERE GONNA WAIT
ONE SECOND WE'RE GOING TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ON FIVE YES. CAN THE CONSULTANT
OF THE UNMODERATED FROM EIGHTEEN
T. CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES IT WAS
THE LAST WEEK OR THAT WE HAVE A
COUPLE HEARING OVER THE CALL.
OKAY ALL RIGHT EXCELLENT WILL BE
WITH YOU IN JUST ONE MOMENT
THANK YOU. WELCOME HOME PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ANOTHER LEYVA
HERE LEYVA HERE WHICH SHOW A
VOTE FOR TEVYE YOU'RE PROTESTING
HERE DELHI DELHI HERE GLAZER
GLAZER HERE MCGUIRE TEN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE ALSO GOING
TO TAKE UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR
MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY ITEMS YOU
WOULD LIKE TO REMOVED FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. VERY GOOD MAN
I'M A CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. IN CENTER TOWN CALENDAR
SENATOR LEYVA HI LEYVA HI-
TELEVOTE. PROTESTS THE- PROTESTS
THE I. DALLI. DALLI I GLAZERS.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE. HANDS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL LEAVE THAT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
OUR LEAD SUPPORT ON SB NINE
FORTY ONE- IS- IS THAT YOU'LL-
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY
OF TWO MINUTES CAN YOU HEAR ME.
WE CAN HEAR YOU I KNOW IT'S A
LITTLE IT'S A LITTLE DIFFERENT
BUT WE- YOUR FIVE. WE CAN HEAR
YOU LOUD AND CLEAR THANK YOU
OKAY- MORNING CHARLIE THAT
MEMBERS OF THE CAP. FIFTY OF MY
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATOR AND I'M ONE
OF THOUSAND MEMBERS. I FOR ONE
DON'T FIVE WITH MORE ACCESS TO
HIGH DEMAND CLASS. TO COLLAB
AGREEMENTS TO LOCAL I. EVEN. YOU
KNOW STATES IS FACING A SHORTAGE
HAS ONLY BEEN EXACT BY THE CO
NINETEEN AND- HOW FOR IN
PARTICULAR ONE OF THE MOST OF
TEACHER SHORTAGE OF IN THE
COUNTRY. SINCE THE START OF HAND
HE JUST BEEN LEAVING THE
PROFESSION AND EVEN FASTER. THE
SAME A TWENTY. INCREASE IN
RETIREMENT DURING THE FIRST THE
PANDEMIC. THE SHORTEST HAVE A
LARGE ON JACKSON AND WILD DURING
HAS ALREADY DIFFICULT FOR PUBLIC
SCHOOL STUDENTS. THE SCARCITY
DESPITE FACTS UNDER SIR. OUR
STUDENTS MANY WHOM LACK. HI CAN
A LACK ACCESS EDUCATION LEARNING
POLICIES STATE WELL TO NUMBER
VACANCY INCREASED PREVIOUS YEARS
THE GREATEST DEMAND WITH HARD TO
STAFF AREAS OF MATH. HI
SPECIALIZED. EVEN THE SUBJECT
AREAS ARE IN HIGH DEMAND WITHOUT
TO TEACH AND HOW FAR IS. AT
OUTCOMES WELCOME TO LIVE OTHER
STATES. SB NINE FOUR ONE WHAT
HOW RELIEVE OF THE CHALLENGES
INVOLVING EDUCATORS GEORGE
ESPECIALLY FOR SMALL AND RURAL
DISTRICTS WITH LIMITED RESOURCES
. MANY EDUCATORS IN SMALL AND
ROAD DISTRICTS HAVE A DIFFICULT
TIME WITH RECOUP RETENTION AN
EDGE. ARE OFTEN TO PLAY MORE
ROLES. FROM C. TO PASS DRIVER
FOR THE F. STUDENT COLTON
SUFFERED WITH STATUS SO THIN. IN
ORDER TO COME. COVER VITAL
FUNCTION NESTLED AND IN MANY
CASES THERE ARE NO AT. AVAILABLE
TO TEACH THESE CORE CLASSES
DESPITE THESE CHALLENGES THIS
BILL WOULD. STUDENTS FROM ALL
READ OF THE STATE. TO ACT AN
ALCOHOL AND- CORE VALUE ACCESS
MISSION. RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR DRIVE VOEPEL THIS BILL
THANK YOU THE YOU VERY MUCH OUR
NEXT WE'RE TO GO TO JEAN LAW.
MORE AND I BELIEVE SHE ANSWER.
NO VERY GOOD- IT T. MODEL IF YOU
CAN BRING UP. MORE WOULD BE
GREAT. HELLO HELLO. HI MY NAME
IS THANK LOT MORE THAN WHAT THE
KNOWN AS JANE COULD. MY AGE YEAR
OLD SON WAS IN IN A MY IMMERSION
PROGRAM IN A PUBLIC SCHOOLAND I
COUNTY UNTIL JUNE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. IN AUGUST OUR DISTRICT TOLD
US THAT TO CONTINUE WITH A
FRENCH LANGUAGE CURRICULUM WE
NEED FOR TRYING TO CAMPUS BUT MY
FAMILY'S HEALTH CONCERNS MADE
RETURNING AT THAT TIME
IMPOSSIBLE. THEN WE WERE TOLD
THE ONLY OPTION FOR REMOTE
LEARNING WOULD BE UNENROLLED
FROM OUR HOME SCHOOL THE ONE
OFFERING THE FRENCH IMMERSION
CURRICULUM AND ENROLL IN A
SEPARATE ENGLISH ONLY SCHOOL.
THIS IS BECAUSE THE TWO REASONS
THE STATE BANNED IN THE HYBRID
MODEL FROM THE YEAR BEFORE IN
PERSON AND REMOTE INSTRUCTION
HAPPENED VENUE CANYON RIGHT AND
THERE HAD BEEN A STATEWIDE
TEACHER SHORTAGE PARENTS OF
LANGUAGE IMMERSION STUDENT COULD
NOT HAVE THEIR CHILDREN RETURNED
IN PERSON LEARNING. VOICED
CONCERNS DISTRICT THEY KNEW THAT
WITHOUT THE TARGET LANGUAGE
CURRICULUM THEIR KIDS WITH THE
PERFECT AND IF THEY CAN'T
LEARNING LAW DURING THE MONTH
REMOTE ERNIE AND THAT IT BOB
COOLEY CAN YOU LEAD TO THEIR
CHILDREN BEING SHOT OUT OF THE-
YEAH. THIS IS A SPECIAL TRUE
PURSUE TO STAY DON'T SPEAK THE
TARGET RANGE AT HOME BECAUSE
LANGUAGE RICK CAN. MORE FELT ANY
OTHER AREA. WHICH POINTS OUT TO
THE DISTRICT THAT WHEN THESE
CHILDREN RETURNED IN PERSON
LEARNING THEIR STRUGGLE WITH
MORE THAN JUST THE LANGUAGE
STUDY BECAUSE MERGING PROGRAM
TEACHES MOST OF THE CURRICULUM
IN THAT TARGET LANGUAGE ONE
STUDENTS NO LONGER MASTER THE
LANGUAGE THEY HAVE TROUBLE
ABSORBING ANY INSTRUCTION.
REGARDLESS OF THE SUBJECT.
RECORDIST THE WITHOUT MORE TEACH
. THERE WAS NOTHING THEY COULD
DO. FOR NOW FOR OUT OUR FEARS
WERE JUST. SOME PARENTS ENERGY
HAVE WHICH TO IN PERSON.
SEPARATE MY TARGET LEARNING LAW
. THAT BEING TOLD BY. HOME
SCHOOL THAT THEIR CHILDREN MAY
NOT BE ALLOWED TO COMPETE THE
PROGRAM YEAR. I HEARD FROM OTHER
PARA. THAT OUR NEIGHBORING THE
HAS THE SAME CHALLENGE. BUT
WHATEVER TO DO HAS BEEN ABLE TO
LANGUAGE MY RESEARCH. I BILL CAN
OFFER HE SEE THIS. BY NAME INTO
COLLABORATE. I THAT YOU DO TO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT WE
WILL TO A SORT THAT IS HERE ROOM
TO ONE HUNDRED ANYONE WANT TO.
BECAUSE OF C. NO ONE I WILL GO
TO THE MODERATOR MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
FORTY ONE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO. SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE FORTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE FORTY ONE.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN
THERE. ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
RECEIVE THEM MY NUMBER.
NINE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY TWELFTH YOU
MAY BE A NEW. ONE HI. HI I AM
SORRY I DIDN'T DAY IT KEEPS
CUTTING OUT I'M JUST IN SUPPORT
OF THE SPELL MY NAME IS AMBER
FUND MONDAY MY SON IS IN A TO A
LANGUAGE PROGRAM IN. UNIFIED
THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AND GIVE THE MAN A
MODERATOR WE WILL GO TO WE HAVE
NO LEAD OPPOSITION IS THERE
ANYONE HERE TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO ONE A META MODERATOR CAN
YOU QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB NINE FORTY ONE PLEASE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN OPPOSITION OF SB. NINE FORTY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF
SB NINE FORTY ONE. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU THINK ABOUT A
MODERATOR OR IT WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE IF ANYONE
HAVE ANY COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS. THANK YOU THE BILL'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR GLAZERS
CENTER PORTANTINO WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE. BY YES WHEN I FELT VERY
GOOD THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR GLAZER MENTAL CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I THEM
NUMBER ONE SB NINE FORTY ONE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE OCHO ABOVE HI THE TROUBLED
AYE COURTESY AYE. CORTES III
GALLEY. KELLY I GLAZER. GLAZER
AYE MCGUIRE. HAND ALL RIGHT. HI
GOOD TIMING THERE SENATOR PAN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL LEAVE
THAT OPEN FOR A HASN'T OF BILLS
OF BOTH YOU KNOW BELIEVE IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS ALL RIGHT WE
ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB THIRTEEN OH TWO CENTER
PORTANTINO PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU MEDICARE'S
INSPECTOR PAN IS HERE I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
BEING WILLING TO STEP IN IF
NEEDED. I APPRECIATE IT- MEMBERS
ARE PROUD TO PRESENT S. B.
THIRTEEN OF TWO HAS YOU. WITH
SAID WE'RE GRAPPLING WITH THE
EFFECTS OF ISOLATION. AND REMOTE
LEARNING BROUGHT ON BY COVERT
NINETEEN AT THEM- I'M SURE MANY
OF YOU'VE HEARD FROM PARENTS YOU
THOSE OF YOU HAVE. CHILDREN OR
GRANDCHILDREN DO YOU KNOW THE
STRUGGLES THAT OUR STUDENTS HAVE
BEEN GOING ON PREPARE THEM AGAIN
AND- THAT THE PANDEMIC.
HIGHLIGHTED STUDY STUDENTS SPEND
ALMOST ONE THIRD OF THEIR LIVES
AT SCHOOL. AND IN MANY CASES
SCHOOL FOR THEIR ONLY ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCE. FORTY
JACKSON A MAJORITY OF STUDENTS
ARE NOT CURRENTLY RECEIVE
RECEIVING THE CARE THEY NEED.
AND MANY STUDENTS MAY NOT HAVE
OTHER AVENUES OF CARE. TWO
THIRDS OF TEACHERS SAY THEY WERE
UNEQUIPPED TO DEAL WITH THEIR
STUDENTS MENTAL HEALTH. TWENTY
TWENTY REPORT BY THE CALIFORNIA
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION FOUND
THAT ONE IN THREE HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS REPORTED FEELING
CHRONICALLY. SAD AND HOPELESS
ONE IN THREE. FRANKLY SAD AND
HOPELESS WITH THE NUMBER RISING
MORE THAN HALF FOR LGBT
STUDENTS. ONE IN SIX HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS REPORTED HAVING
CONSIDERED SUICIDE IN THE PAST
YEAR AND ONE IN THREE LGBT
STUDENTS. HAVE REPORTED THE SAME
. THESE ISSUES MAY BE ESPECIALLY
PRESSING FOR STUDENTS OF COLOR
WHO'VE ALREADY FACE DISPARITIES
IN CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM
SUSPENSION AND EXPULSION.
EXPANDING WELLNESS CENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOLS WOULD
MEET THE GROWING NEEDS FOR
MENTAL HEALTH CARE MONTH OUR
STUDENTS. PRIORITIZING THE
MENTAL HEALTH OF STUDENTS AT A
CRUCIAL TIME IS KEY FOR LONG
TERM WELL BEING AN ACADEMIC
SUCCESS. UNADDRESSED ANXIETY
DEPRESSION AND TRAUMA CAN IMPACT
FUTURE WELL BEING AN
INTERPERSONAL RELATIONSHIP
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT. AND
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY AS WELL AS
INCREASING DEMANDS ON SOCIAL AND
HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS. TODAY I'M
PRESENTING THIS BILL TO EXPAND
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ON
OUR HIGH SCHOOL CAMPUSES WHICH
IS DESPERATELY NEEDED. I HAVE-
MICHELLE NEW ONE- PRESIDENT OF
THE CHICAGO SCHOOL OF
PROFESSIONAL PSYCHOLOGY BASED IN
LA. AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ONE FOR FREE THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER PORTANTINO A
MEMBERS I'M JUST GOING TO ASK TO
MAKE SURE YOUR MOM YOUR MIKE IS
ON AND YOU SPEAK DIRECTLY INTO
IT- FOLKS LISTENING TO HIM A
LITTLE BIT OF A HARD TIME
HEARING. AND FOR PRESENTERS IT'S
A LITTLE CHALLENGING BECAUSE
MICROPHONE IS SO LOW- WORLD
GETTING USED TO OUR NEW A NEW
SETTING HERE SO WHEN YOU'RE
PRESENTING JUST- SPEAK UP A BIT.
OKAY WE ARE GOING TO GO TO YOUR
LEAD WITNESS- DOCTOR NEW LAN
BUTTON THE ONLY IF YOU'RE READY
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME IS DR
MICHELLE KNEELAND I'M PRESIDENT
OF THE CHICAGO SCHOOL
HEADQUARTERED IN LOS ANGELES I'M
A RESIDENT. OF PASADENA
CALIFORNIA. OVER EIGHT MILLION
CHILDREN IN THE UNITED STATES OF
LIVING WITH A MENTAL HEALTH
ILLNESS SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
THE PANDEMIC THERE. THERE HAS
BEEN A 24% INCREASE. IN MENTAL
HEALTH RELATED EMERGENCY ROOM
VISITS FOR FIVE TO ELEVEN YEAR
OLD. AND A 31% INCREASE FOR
TWELVE TO SEVEN YEAR OLD SUICIDE
IS NOW THE SECOND LEADING CAUSE
OF DEATH. FOR PEOPLE BETWEEN THE
AGES OF TEN AND TWENTY FOUR.
SINCE THE START OF THE PANDEMIC.
WE HAVE SEEN A 50% JUMP IN
SUICIDE ATTEMPTS AMONG YOUNG
GIRL. AND A 4% JUMP FOR BOYS. I
AM HERE TO VOICE OUR SUPPORT OF
SENATOR PORTANTINO'S SB THIRTY
TO THIRTEEN OH TWO. TO FUND
WELLNESS CENTERS AND OTHER VITAL
LIFESAVING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR STUDENTS IN OUR
SCHOOL. THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGISTS
RECOMMENDS A RATIO OF ONE SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGIST. FOR FIVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
COMPREHENSIVE SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGICAL SERVICES. CURRENT
DAY AFTER AND NATIONAL. OF ONE
TO ONE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND
ELEVEN. OUR MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
IS FAILING OUR CHILDREN. NOT
ENOUGH ATTENTION AND FUNDING IS
BEING GIVEN TO DIE RECHTE
SERVICES IN SCHOOL AS WELL AS TO
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. THREE
YEARS AGO I PERSONALLY TRIED TO
HELP THE PRINCIPAL AND STUDENTS
OF THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
MIDDLE SCHOOL WHO ARE FACING AN
ALARMING INCREASE IN LOSS OF
LIFE TO SUICIDE FOR MIDDLE
SCHOOLERS. BUT AFTER SEVERAL
MEETINGS WE WERE PREVENTED FROM
HELPING THE STUDENTS BECAUSE OF
LEGAL AND BUREAUCRATIC OBSTACLES
THE OUTCOME LOSS OF LIFE. IN THE
END THE PRINCIPAL AND STUDENTS
AT THE SCHOOL DID NOT RECEIVE
THE URGENT SUPPORT THAT THEY
REQUIRE. THE CHICAGO SCHOOL IS
CURRENTLY TRAINING ONE OUT OF
EVERY TEN PSYCHOLOGISTS AND
COUNSELORS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ALONE. WE HAVE
HUNDREDS OF OUR STUDENTS WORKING
IN COMMUNITY BASED CLINICS AND
SCHOOLS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
PROVIDING FREE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AS PART OF THEIR
TRAINING. NO MATTER WHAT WE DO
IT IS NOT ENOUGH I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT TO THIS BILL ON BEHALF
OF OUR MOST PRECIOUS COMMODITY
WHICH IS OUR CHILDREN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY WE WILL NOW COME TO
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED AND IT
ANYBODY IN HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. SEEING
NONE MADAM MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN OH TWO ON THE LINE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY
NUMBER TWO. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. THIRTEEN OH
TWO. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. NINE SIXTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORNING MY NAME IS JEFF
WEINER I'M CALLING IN FROM
JEWISH FAMILY AND CHILDREN'S
SERVICES IN THAT AREA- WE DO
CLINICAL MENTAL HEALTH WORK WITH
CHILDREN AND WE ALSO WORK WITH
THEIR PARENTS AND TEACHERS TO
SUPPORT THEM AT SCHOOL AND AT
HOME. AND THAT YOU'VE ALREADY
HEARD AND YOU CAN PROBABLY
IMAGINE- WE'VE SEEN A HUGE
GROWTH IN THE LAST TWO YEARS IN
THE NUMBERS OF STUDENTS AND
PARENTS ARE COMING TO US WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. THE
ISOLATION FROM THEIR FRIENDS AND
THEIR SOCIAL SUPPORT IS
AFFECTING STUDENTS ACROSS THE
BOARD ALL STUDENTS. NOT JUST THE
ONES WHO PREVIOUSLY HAD MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES. AND IT'S SAFE TO
ASSUME THAT OUR STUDENTS ARE
RETURNING TO IN PERSON OR NAY.
ALMOST ALL OF THEM WILL HAVE
FACE SOME LEVEL OF ADVERSITY.
THAT'S WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO
FOCUS ON SUPPORTING THE SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL NEEDS OF EVERY
STUDENT. AND AT THE SAME TIME
IDENTIFYING THOSE WHO MIGHT NEED. TO BE REFERRED TO MORE
INTENSIVE SUPPORT. COOL WELLNESS
CENTER MEET THAT. BECAUSE THEY
ARE STATE PLACE WHERE STUDENT GO
TO DECOMPRESS AND IF THEY WISH.
TO TALK TO A COUNSELOR OR
ANOTHER TRAINED PROFESSIONAL
MENTAL HEALTH. AND IF THE LOW
STAKES ASPECT OF WELLNESS
CENTERS THE ACCESSIBILITY THE
FACT THAT THEY'RE WELCOMING.
PLACES FOR ANY STUDENTS TO
COMMENT THAT MAKES THEM
ATTRACTIVE FOR THE WIDEST RANGE
OF KIDS. AND WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
IDENTIFYING AND REACHING THIS
LARGE GROUP OF STUDENTS WHO MAY
HAVE ON RECOGNIZE TRAUMA FROM
THE LAST TWO YEARS. AS I SAID
WELL THIS CENTERS PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL HERE ONE MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORTS THAT HELP KIDS BE
RESILIENT. AND THEY ALSO PROVIDE
REFERRALS AND LINKAGES TO MORE
INTENSIVE SERVICES- AND AT
PRESENT A LOT OF USER I'M
ARTICULATED WRAP UP YOU WERE
REALLY ONLY SUPPOSED TO STATE
YOUR NAME AND YOUR SUPPORT BY
LETTING YOU GO ON BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T HAVE A SECOND LEAD
SUPPORT. NO SAW JUST WRAP UP BY
SAYING THIS BUILDING MINUTES GO
WELL CENTERS WITH THE SAN. AND
FOR THAT REASON I URGE YOU TO
VOTE I ON THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT- WE WILL GO NOW
TO OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO LISTED
LEAD OPPOSITION ANYONE HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED- I'M SO
SORRY OKAY OF LET'S KEEP GOING
SORRY ABOUT THAT NEXT PERSON IN
THE QUEUE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
LINE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THAT ENSURE MEMBERS LED TO SOME
OF THE QUESTIONS DIRECTOR OF
STATE POLICY OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES AND CALLING IN SUPPORT
SB THIRTEEN IF YOU LOOK BACK TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE BILLS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
. I LEFT A COMMENT IN. THE PORT
IS NINE EIGHTEEN. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER WITH SEIU
CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN SUPPORT- IN
CONCEPTS WE WILL WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR BECAUSE WE SEE A VALUABLE
ROLE FOR OUR WORKFORCE AND
MOVING ALONG. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL
RIGHT NOW WE WILL GO TO ANY LEAD
OPPOSITION HERE IN TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED OR ANY OPPOSITION SEEING
NONE MATAMATA READY TO HAVE IN.
OKAY SO I THOUGHT SHE'S TO SPEAK
OF MEMORY TO HAVE ANYONE ON THE
LINE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN OH
TWO. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION SB
THIRTEEN OH TWO. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTEEN OH TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN THERE. WE HAVE NO
COMMENTS IN OFFICE ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. IF YOU HAVE ONE LINE. HE
JUST A MOMENT WHILE WE GET THAT
THE LINE NUMBER THANK YOU. MY
TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING-
WE'RE ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT- SIX-
HOW DO YOU RIGHT TACKLE THE
ISSUE THE WHITE THE ON BEHALF OF
THE DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
AND WE ARE SUPPORT THANK YOU
TERRIFIC THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
IT WILL NOW BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. A SENATOR PAM. BUT
THANK YOU SIR I'M- AND I DON'T
KNOW I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR-
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN ADDRESSING
HEALTH WANT ONE THINGS I DID
WANT TO MAKE NOTE IS THAT- I
KNOW THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
EMPHASIS ON THE LAST TWO YEARS
OF THE PANDEMIC. BUT ACTUALLY
NEAR TIMES ACTUALLY REPORTED.
RATES OF DEPRESSION ANXIETY IN
CHILDREN WERE RISING BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC AND I KNOW THAT- THERE
PORTANTINO YOU AND WE'VE WORKED
TOGETHER ON ACTUALLY DRESSING
MEDICAL ISSUES PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC BECAUSE OF THIS. SO YOU
CERTAINLY VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS- YOU KNOW- IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT THE PANDEMIC- WE HAVE WE
HAVE SOME SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES
WITH HELPING SUPPORT THE MENTAL
HEALTH OF OUR- CHILDREN OF OUR
STUDENTS AND SCHOOL AND SO
FORTH. I GUESS JUST ONE BRIEF
QUESTION AND THEN OF COURSE I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO MOVE IT TO
STOP THE PROTAGONIST AT. THIS
ONE TIME MONEY OR DO YOU SEE HOW
DO YOU SEE BECAUSE WILL YOU
STAND UP THE WELLNESS CENTER-
HOW DO I CONTINUE TO SUPPORT TO
SUSTAIN THEM. IT'S ACTUALLY MY
HOPE IT'S ACTUALLY MY HOPE. THAT
IT WOULD BE AN ON GOING.
EXCELLENT WELL AGAIN I'M HAPPY
TO MOVE THE BILL TO PUT THE TIME
AND THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
PANAMINT GO TO CENTRO CHAU BOGAN
AND CENTERPLATE. BUT THE MORE
AND THANK YOU CENTER PROJECT
FOR- BRING THIS BILL FOURTH. YOU%
KNOW AS A NEW MEMBER TO THE
LEGISLATURE- AS OF LAST YEAR
MEANING WITH PEOPLE ACROSS THE
STATE IT IS. MIND BOGGLING THE
AMOUNT OF CONCERN THAT WE HAVE
WITH THE HUMOR HEALTH AND MANY
MANY SPACES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- AND I AM JUST I'M- VERY
HOPEFUL THAT THIS HOPEFULLY WILL
GO FORTH AND MOVE FORWARD AND
ADDRESS EACH OF THEIR CHILDREN-
I MYSELF HAVE KNOWN. JUST ONE
FAMILY MEMBER WHO- YOU KNOW
WITHIN THE PAST TWO YEARS
ATTEMPTED SUICIDE- IN A IT WAS
HEARTBREAKING HEARTBREAKING SO
AND IT'S IT. IT'S PERSONAL FOR
ME AND- I THINK FOR MANY MANY
PEOPLE THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA ONE
THING I DID WANT TO MENTION
REALLY QUICK IS THE- MAKE SURE
THAT WE CREATE PROBLEMS. THAT
WILL ADDRESS THE ISSUE BUT NOT
JUST THAT THAT AS ELECTED. WE
WORK ON POLICY THAT HELPS
SUPPORT OUR FAMILIES SO THAT
THEY CAN BE HEALTHY BEGINNING
WITH THE PARENTS- AND THE CARE
GIVERS BECAUSE WE ARE. CREATING
AN ENVIRONMENT THAT'S REALLY IN
MY OPINION MY PERSONAL HUMBLE
OPINION BASED ON MANY
CONVERSATIONS THAT I HAVE TO
ROUTE MY DISTRICT. THAT'S VERY
HOSTILE TO FAMILIES AND
EXPECTING PARENTS TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE COST OF LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA- IN PROVIDING THAT
QUALITY OF LIFE IT'S BECOMING
VERY VERY DIFFICULT SO I'M
HOPING THAT AS ELECTED. AS
LEADERS IN WHICHEVER SPACE WERE
WORKING WHETHER IT'S LOCAL OR AT
THE STATE LEVEL THAT WE WORK
TOWARDS- POLICY THAT BRINGS HOW
MANY WITHIN OUR FAMILIES. AND
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
WITHIN OUR STATE AND OUR NATION
BECAUSE- GOODNESS GRACIOUS WE'RE
IN TROUBLE AND MANY MANY PEOPLE
ARE FEELING THAT WEIGHT- WITHIN
THEIR BEHAVIOR HEALTH AND IT
AFFECTS THEIR- PHYSICAL WELL
BEING THEIR EMOTIONAL AND EVEN
THEIR SPIRITUAL. SO ON THAT
FRONT I AM HAPPY TO SUPPORT HIS
BILL TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTRO CHOI BOGUE. CENTER GLAZER
. THANK YOU CHIRLA. AYE SENATOR
PORTANTINO I THROUGH THE ONE TO
ADD MY VOICE AT STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE LEGISLATION. IT'LL BE
MORE IMPORTANT THAT. THE NUMBER
THAT WE TAKE ACTION IN THE
SPACE- THIS YESTERDAY PROVIDE
NUMBER BY STAFF WHO. HAD A
FAMILY FOR THAT PERSON SCHOOL.
BY AND WE KNOW THAT IS JUST THAT
. A VERY DIFFICULT SITUATION- WE
WERE ABLE TO WORK TOGETHER LAST
YEAR ON BY. EIGHT TO FOURTEEN
BOND MEASURE TO ADD I HAVE A
BILLION DOLLARS IN FOR. THIS
TYPE OF MENTAL HEALTH CENTERS WE
DON'T KNOW THAT WITH THAT BILL
IS GOING TO GO WITH THEM
ASSEMBLY AND WHAT KIND OF ISSUE
SHOULD. RESULTS IN ITS- OF
PASSAGE OR NOT. BUT I CERTAINLY
SEE THIS AS ANOTHER. ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO DO WHAT IS RIGHT
. HAPPY TO. THE BILL APPROVED.
TIME THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZERS
SENATE ALL. TO GIVE YOU AN OFFER
TO THIS IS A POLICY COMMITTEE
ALL THERE'S LOT OF MY AND I'M-
WE SPOKE EARLIER- BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE IN I WHEN YOU'VE GOT.
YOU KNOW WE PUT MONEY IN
CALIFORNIA TO A LOT OF THINGS A
LOT OF MONEY. SO CAN YOU L.
NIGHT EXPERIENCE IN MY DISTRICT-
THE LACK OF EVEN THAT THEY HAVE
THE ABILITY TO GET THE WORKERS
EVEN IF WE HAVE THE MONEY SO
THIS IS VERY BROAD AND- AND WHEN
HE CAN YOU JUST SHARE YOUR
VISION ON HOW YOU. SEE THIS
ROLLING OUT AND WHAT AND WHAT
AREAS ARE WE GONNA BE ABLE TO
FILL THOSE SLOTS AND WITH WHAT
KIND OF- PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
FILL THOSE ACTUAL SLOTS TO GET
THE JOB DONE- IT'S A GREAT
QUESTION AND ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY WE LEFT. THE IMPLEMENTATION
PROCESS I RECOGNIZE. PERSONAL I
WANT TO THANK. MY COLLEAGUES-
FOR THEIR COMMENTS AND FOR THE
CONVERSATION I MEAN THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT. IT'S IMPORTANT
SUBJECT. WE LEFT IT BROAD
BECAUSE I RECOGNIZE THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE. COUNTY TO COUNTY
WITH THE SERVICES THAT ARE
NECESSARY AND NEEDED- ONE SCHOOL
MAY NEED A PHYSICAL SPACE
BECAUSE THEY ALREADY HAVE.
SUFFICIENT COUNSELORS AND OTHER
SCHOOL MAY. NEED ONE TYPE OF
ACUTE. HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS
SO WE SORT OF CREATED A MENU. OF
OPTIONS THAT WOULD BE ELIGIBLE
UNDER THIS AND- WE THINK IN
ORDER. TO MAKE. THE H. STRONG
DIFFERENCE ON A CAMPUS. WE
NEEDED TO HAVE. SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES. HIGH SCHOOL BY HIGH
SCHOOL SO THAT'S WHY. IN LOOKING
AT THE NUMBERS WE THINK TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER CAMPUS. WILL WILL DO. THE
JOB- WE'RE LOOKING AT A VERY-
VARIOUS DIFFERENT FUNDING
SOURCES- OBVIOUSLY THERE'S GOING
TO BE DISCUSSED IN THE FISCAL
COMMITTEE- BUT YOU ALSO
HIGHLIGHTED. IN THIS THE CHICAGO
SCHOOL MENTIONED. YOU KNOW WE'RE
TRYING TO GET AS MANY STUDENTS
THROUGH. THE PIPELINE AS
POSSIBLE TO MEET THE NEEDS ON
OUR CAMPUSES AND THERE'S A
NUMBER OF OTHER BILLS TO TRY TO
STREAMLINE THAT PROCESS. BECAUSE
THERE IS A RECOGNITION IN THE
LEGISLATURE THAT WE HAVE TO GET
PEOPLE THROUGH THE SYSTEM- WITH
THEIR CERTIFICATES WITH THE
TRAINING. SOONER QUICKER FASTER
BECAUSE THE NEED IS SO GREAT-
THE BILL IS NOT ADDRESSING THAT
PIECE BECAUSE OTHER LEGISLATION
IS. BUT WE'RE TRYING TO BE BROAD
ENOUGH AND FLEXIBLE ENOUGH. TO
GIVE DISTRICTS THE ABILITY TO
MEET THE DEMANDS ON THE LOCAL
LEVEL. THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THAT I AND YOU KNOW. WE WORKED
ON THAT LAST YEAR GIVING THE-
ACTUAL TRAINING FOR TEACHERS TO
IDENTIFY. WHERE THERE IS GOING
TO- WHEN THEY- THE ACTUAL
TRANSFERRED SO THEY CAN SEE IT
BEFORE IT HAPPENS AND SO AND I
KNOW THAT BILL GOT HUNG UP IN
THE ASSEMBLY LAST YEAR AND
DIDN'T GET OUT AND SO. I'M
HOPING THIS IS KIND OF ALONG
THOSE LINES WERE WEAK WE CAN
EDUCATE. YOU KNOW NOT ONLY THE
TEACHER BUT THE BUS DRIVERS IN
THE IN THE FOLKS ALONG THE WAY
THIS TO BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY WHEN
THEY SEE A STUDENT THAT IS-
ISOLATING THEMSELVES OR OR WHAT
HAVE YOU AND GET IT GOING
TOWARDS THAT PATH OF- YOU
NEEDING SOME COUNSELING YEAH.
EARLIER THAN LATER SOONER THAN
LATER SO- I'M GONNA SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TODAY A BIG GONNA BE REALLY
WATCHING FOR THE DETAIL OF HOW
IT COMES OUT BECAUSE I THINK
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE IMPORTANT
PART. OF HOW IT GETS IMPLEMENTED
IN NOT JUST THE MONEY PART OF IT
BUT ACTUALLY HOW IT WORKS ON THE
GROUND SO I APPRECIATE YOU
STAYING ON THE FOCUS OF THIS AND
I THINK THERE IS IT A TRUE NEED
FOR. AND MADAM CHAIR IF I MAY-
THE FISCAL QUESTION AND THE
STABILITY OF THE PROGRAM MATTERS
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THE BEST THING
IS TO HAVE WELL TRAINED.
COUNSELLORS SOCIAL WORKERS ON
CAMPUS YEAR IN YEAR OUT YOU KNOW
IT WHO WORK FOR THE DISTRICT OF
AND THAT'S THAT THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE STRIVING FOR. IS TO HAVE
THAT STABILITY IN THE SERVICE
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T EVEN THOUGH
THE STUDENTS CHANGE EVERY YEAR
THEIR DEMANDS DON'T GO AWAY THEY
NEED THAT TABILITY SO THAT'S
THAT'S THE GOAL. ARE YOU ALSO
REFERENCED THE TRAINING THE
OTHER FOLKS ON CAMPUS THAT'S
VERY COMPANION TO THIS IS IF THE
TEACHER THE BUS DRIVER THE
CAFETERIA WORKER IS TRAINED TO
SEE THE WARNING SIGNS OF MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES THEN THEY CAN%
DIRECT THAT STUDENT. TO THAT
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONAL WHO
WOULD ALSO BE ON THAT CAMPUS SO
THEY WORKING COMPLEMENT TO EACH
OTHER THE KEY IS TO CREATE A
SYSTEM THAT STABLE. WHICH
REQUIRES THE FUNDINGAND THEN TO
HAVE A WORK FORCE THAT'S ABLE TO
DO THE JOB ON A LONG TERM BASIS
AND SO THAT'S THE OVERALL GOAL
SO THANK YOU. WE TAKE THAT AS
YOUR CLOTHES MAY TAKE THAT AS
MICHAEL THANK YOU SIR THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR PAN
MADAM. CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. I NUMBER THREE S. B.
THIRTEEN. VOTE THE- IS TO PASS
FIRST BE RE. TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATION. SENATOR LEYVA AYE
LEYVA AYE OCHO ABODE HI. OTOBO
GUY COURTESY I. PROTEST THE I.
DALLY. DALLY I GLAZER. AS OUR
AYE MCGUIRE HAN ALL RIGHT CAN I
. THANK YOU HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO
GET OUT WHAT WILL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBER OUR NEXT ROOM
TO GO TO FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
SB TWELVE NINETY NINE SENATOR
MEN I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR A
GETTING HERE POST HASTE 2% YOUR
BILL WE APPRECIATE THAT AND YOU
MAKE IT BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU FOR LEYVA THANK
YOU FOR. THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND TO COMMITTEE
STAFF. AND WORKING CLOSELY WITH
US ON THIS BILL. I TOLD NINETY
NINE RELATES AN IMPORTANT
ACADEMIC PROGRAM PROVIDED THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA. THERE IS
A CALIFORNIA STATE SUMMER SCHOOL
IN MATHEMATICS AND SCIENCE
PROGRAM OR COSMOS. WHAT TWELVE
NINETY NINE DOES SPECIFICALLY IS
IT EXTENDS A SUNSET DATE FOR THE
COSMO PROGRAM. BY FIVE YEARS
INSURING IT CONTENT CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE CRUCIAL EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS
ACROSS THE STATE. BECAUSE
PROGRAMS OVERSEEN BY THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA AND
PROVIDES AN INTENSIVE ACADEMIC
EXPERIENCE FOR STUDENTS. WHO
WISH TO LEARN ADVANCED
AESTHETICS SCIENCE BIOLOGY AND
ENGINEERING. PREPARING THEM FOR
FUTURE CAREERS IN THESE
RESPECTIVE AREAS AND I SHOULD
CLARIFY THIS IS FOR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS. IT'S A FOUR WEEK
RESIDENTIAL ACADEMIC PROGRAM-
CITED AT FOUR DIFFERENT CAMPUSES
UC DAVIS. UC SAN DIEGO UC SANTA
CRUZ AND UC IRVINE WHICH AS YOU
KNOW I HAVE A CLOSE RELATIONSHIP
WITH. AND IS IN MY DISTRICT. I
THIS UNIQUE PROGRAM- PREPARES
AND- OUR- TOP HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS IN STEM- FOR THAT NEXT
LEVEL PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE AN INTENSIVE STEM.
INSTRUCTION I EACH OF THESE FOUR
CAMPUSES TYPICALLY HOSTS TWO
HUNDRED MOE STUDENTS EACH
SUMMER WITH THE GOAL OF CREATING
AN ENVIRONMENT THAT FOSTERS
STUDENT INTEREST. AND AWARENESS
OF EDUCATIONAL AND CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES IN THESE FIELDS-
IS SOMEONE WHO IS THE CHILD OF-
STEM PEOPLE MYSELF MY DAD WAS
AN- AEROSPACE ENGINEER WHOSE-
GOT A PHD IN MECHANICAL
ENGINEERING. MY MOM WAS A
CHEMISTRY PHD WHO ENDED UP
WORKING AND- FROM SEMICONDUCTOR
CHIPS. I'M NOT A LAWYER SO WHAT
FAR FROM THAT FIELD BUT I HAVE A
DAUGHTER. AND TWO SONS WHO I
HOPE WILL END UP IN SPAM. I AND
ONE THING I KNOW ABOUT THIS
PROGRAM IS 52% OF THE PEOPLE IN
IT ARE YOUNG GIRLS I WHICH IS
AMAZING IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE
TALK ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF.
HAVING MORE GENDER EQUITY IN
STEM THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT
ACTUALLY GET THAT DONE. I TOLD
NINETY NINE TO INSURE THAT THE
COSMOS PROGRAM CURRENTLY SET TO
EXPIRE AT THE END OF THIS YEAR
CAN CONTINUE TO SHAPE THE LIVES
OF YOUNG STUDENTS- SEE SO THIS
IS- I JUST WANNA CLARIFY AND
ACCEPTING COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
WHICH FIX A TECHNICAL ERROR MADE
IN DRAFTING THAT REGIONAL
LANGUAGE I WOULD KNOW TO SB
TWELVE NINETY NINE IS SUPPORTED
AND SPONSORED BY THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA. AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION WITH ME HERE TO
TESTIFY IN PERSON TODAY WE HAVE-
NEIL'S RUMBEK JANSEN- THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF YOU SEE
BECAUSE THOSE AND A PROFESSOR OF
MECHANICAL ENGINEERING AND
AEROSPACE ENGINEERING
MATHEMATICS AND THEN ALSO
JOINING US FOR THE UC OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT TO ANSWER
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IS TYLER
AGUILAR. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
SENATOR MEN ARE YOUR FIRST
WITNESS HAS TWO MINUTES I GUESS
THAT WOULD BE TYLER OVER THIRTY
A GOOD AS GOOD A- MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS TYLER YOU ARE NOT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA I
WANT TO THANK CENTERMAN FOR
OFFERING SB TWELVE NINETY NINE-
WITH ME TODAY IS THE SENATOR
MENTIONED BILL'S GONE BACK
JENSEN- HE'S THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF YOU SEE BECAUSE MOST
AND ALSO HAS A NEW APPOINTMENT
AS A FACULTY MEMBER UC DAVIS. W.
AN OVERVIEW OF THE PROGRAM AND
ALSO TALK A LITTLE ABOUT THE
IMPACTS THAT HAS ON CALIFORNIA'S
STUDENTS TERRIFIC THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WELCOME THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ONE OF
THEM CHAR EARN. SENATORS FOR.
TAKING TIME TO LISTEN TO BECAUSE
MOST. PRECEDED SO I'VE BEEN INTO
. TWICE FOR MILK ON ANDERSON I'M
THE EXECUTIVE TO. SINCE THOUSAND
FOURTEEN UP BECAUSE OF PROGRAM.
AND THE- OF MAKE. AND AEROSPACE
ENGINEERING AS WELL AS- ARE
TAUGHT IN. A COST MOTIONS
THOUSAND AND FOUR SO I KNOW THE
PROGRAM VERY WELL AS AN
INSTRUCTOR- AND I'VE MY OWN SON
HAS GONE THROUGH THE PROGRAM- SO
I'M HERE TO. TO ANSWER WHATEVER
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. SO APART
FROM WHAT HAS ALREADY BEEN SAID
THE PROGRAM IS- THIS OBVIOUSLY
FOR EXCELLENCE IN IN HIGH
SCHOOL. TRANSITION INTO COLLEGE
AND WE'RE TRYING TO INSPIRED
THESE YOUNG BRILLIANT MINDS. TO
REALLY BECOME A PART OF THE
PIPELINE OF EXCELLENCE INTO THE
CALIFORNIA INDUSTRY- WE HAVE
SOME. VERY GOOD EXAMPLES OF THAT
HAPPENING THE PROGRAM HAVING
EXISTED NOW FOR MORE THAN TWO
DECADES. THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS ALL HIGH- AS CENTER MAN
WAS SAYING WE HAVE ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
STUDENTS ON EACH CAMPUS NOW THE
PROGRAM HAS GROWN. CONSISTENTLY
OVER THE YEARS AT LEAST I HAVE
BEEN- THE DIRECTOR FROM ABOUT
SEVEN HUNDRED STUDENTS WE SERVED
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN UNTIL
NOW. NINE HUNDRED AND ALMOST
FIFTY- LAST YEAR. WE HAD ONE OFF
YOUR TWENTY TWENTY OF COURSE
WHERE WE HAVE TO CANCEL. OF SO
WE ARE TRYING TO INCREASE THE
SERVICE TO- THE STATE AND TO THE
STUDENTS. WE HAVE. FIVE THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED OR SIX HUNDRED
APPLICANTS THIS YEAR- MOST OF
THEM ARE ACTUALLY HIGHLY
QUALIFIED STUDENTS FOR THOSE A
GREAT DEMAND FOR THE PROGRAM AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE TO. TURN
AWAY MANY QUALIFIED STUDENTS
SIMPLY BECAUSE OF. THE
LIMITATIONS TO SPACE AND
RESOURCES FOR ONE TWO FOUR- THE
PROGRAM IS BROKEN DOWN INTO
CLUSTERS OF MANY DIFFERENT
TOPICS SO THAT'S REALLY WHERE
THE DIVERSE CITY COMES IN AND IN
FACT THAT'S WHERE WE- I THINK
HAVE SUCCESS IN GENDER EQUITY OF
IT IN THE PROGRAM. WE HAVE
EVERYTHING FROM MECHANICAL
ENGINEERING TO MATHEMATICS
BIOLOGY TO. ALL SORTS OF THINGS
GOING ON AGRICULTURAL TECHNOLOGY
SO THERE'S A WIDE SPECTRUM OF
THINGS GOING ON. WE ALSO HAVE
SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS IN
FINANCIAL NEED- VERY MUCH SO AT
THE SAME LEVEL AS THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA SO IF STUDENTS
HAVE FINANCIAL NEED WE CAN
SUPPORT THEM THE ADMISSIONS IS
NEED BLIND SO WE SIMPLY GO IN
AND WE SUPPORT THE STUDENTS
BASED ON THE PHONE- THE FAMILY-
FINANCIAL SITUATIONS. I AM IT'S
ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE K. OF FAMILY
INCOME YOU'VE GOT A FULL
FELLOWSHIP IF YOU ARE BETWEEN
SEVENTY FIVE AND TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY. THEN THE RESORT OF
ILLINOIS RAMPANT ABOVE A HUNDRED
FIFTY SO ONE AT THIS POINT WE DO
NOT PORTABLE BUT WE FOLLOW THAT.
VERY CLOSELY WE RAISE THOSE
FUNDS. FROM PRIVATE. FOR VERY
GOOD THANK YOU MUCH MR ACTION WE
HAVE YOUR- AND- IT MEMBER MAY OR
MAY NOT HAVE QUESTIONS SO WE
KNOW YOU'LL BE READY THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT DO WE HAVE ANYBODY
HERE IN TWENTY ONE HUNDRED WHO
WISH TO. GIVE THEIR SUPPORT COME
ON FORWARD. MARK EPSTEIN
CALIFORNIAN FUNDAMENTAL
TECHNOLOGY EDUCATION NETWORK
SUPPORT ON THIS HOWEVER WOULD
ADD THAT WE NEED TO GO FURTHER.
THIS TYPE OF PROGRAM WE NEED TO
EXPAND IT ALSO FROM THE UC'S TO
THE CSU SYSTEM. AND BEYOND JUST
THE SUMMER PROGRAM TO SOMETHING
YEAR ROUND. COMPARED TO SEVERAL
OTHER STATES BOTH OUR TEACHERS
AND STUDENTS LAG BEHIND. IN
TECHNOLOGY IN DIGITAL SKILL SETS
GRANT YET THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEE NO ONE ELSE IN TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED MADAME MODERATOR TO HAVE
ANYBODY ON THE LINE WHO WISHES
TO TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWELVE NINETY NINE IF SO PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT SB. TWELVE
NINETY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWELVE NINETY
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
THERE. WE HAVE NO COMMENT AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MA'AM. BUT THE MINIMUM MODERATOR
RIGHT WE HAVE NO ONE LISTED AS
LEAD OPPOSITION. I DON'T SEE
ANYONE HERE IN TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION MADAME MODERATOR WE
WILL GO BACK TO YOU AND SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ON THE LINE WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN A POSITION
OF S. B. TWELVE. NINE NINE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF SB
TWELVE NINETY NINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE. AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF SB
TWELVE NINETY NINE. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN THERE. WE
HAVE NO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF
SB TWELVE NINETY NINE THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMUNITY I KNOW
THAT SENATOR GLAZER HAS SOME
COMMENTS THAT WILL GO TO SENATOR
PAM. THANK YOU- THIS IS A
FANTASTIC PROGRAM AND- I'M VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF EXTENDING ITS LIFE
AND THAT THE GOOD WORK THAT IT
DOES BUT THE ISSUE THAT I HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT ON THIS BILL IS
THE- IS THE INCREASE IN TUITION
AND FEES- AND SO I I'D BE IN
CITY HEARING FROM THE AUTHOR
ABOUT THAT THE REASON THAT WE
NEED TO DO THAT AT THIS POINT IN
TIME- I KNOW THAT- YOU KNOW TO.
THE REGION'S GET TO DO WHATEVER
THEY WANT TO DO WE ARE ADVISORY
SO IT'S INTERESTING THAT THIS
BILL WAS THE- PRODUCT OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO BEGIN WITH- WHEN
I THINK EVERYONE WOULD SAY IT'S
A WONDERFUL PROGRAM. DOING
REALLY GOOD WORK AND CREATING
THAT PIPELINE SO IMPORTANT BUT I
WANT TO ASK. TO THE CHAIR. IF WE
COULD HEAR ABOUT THE
JUSTIFICATION FOR THE FEE AND
TUITION INCREASES AND WHY WE
SHOULD DO THAT VERSUS THE REGION
. I APPRECIATE THE QUESTION
SENATOR- SO. THAT THE FETUS TO
BE CLEAR THIS IS NOT REQUIRE OR
CREATE A TUITION INCREASE OR FEE
INCEASE. MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT ALLOWS. THE PROGRAM TO GO
UP TO A 5% INCREASE IN THE
TUITION AND FEES- IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE TUITION WAS FOUR
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
FOUR DOLLARS- AND THE- THIS IS A
MODEST POTENTIAL INCREASE THAT-
WOULD ALLOW. THE PROGRAM TO
CONTINUE. DEALING WITH THE
RISING EXPENSES THAT I THINK-
PROFESSOR- ONDECK JENSEN-
MENTIONED EARLIER DUE TO BOTH
INCREASING ENROLLMENT AS WELL AS
THAT JUST RISING INFLATION THAT
WE'RE EXPERIENCING- YEAH YOU
KNOW AS FAR AS FEES NOT CREATE
ONE THING IT'S JUST ABOUT THIS
PROGRAM IS YOU KNOW IS THAT IT.
IS AN OPTIONAL PROGRAM FOR HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS IT'S NOT HI READ
ITSELF IS NOT SOMETHING TO
IMPEACH ANY PATHWAYS
NOTIFICATION- IN THERE ARE AS I
UNDERSTAND IT SIGNIFICANT
SCHOLARSHIPS AVAILABLE FOR THOSE
WHO ARE IN NEED TO CAN
DEMONSTRATE THAT SO. APART IS
THE CROSS SUBSIDIES THAT ACCRUE
TO YOU KNOW STUDENTS THAT ARE.
LOWER INCOME AND SO I THINK THE
GOALS OF THIS PROGRAM IS YOU
KNOW- WORTHWHILE- THE MODEST
POTENTIAL FEE AND TUITION
INCREASES HERE ARE MEANT TO BE
CONTENT WITH THOSE GOALS. BUT I
WOULD ALSO ALLOW. A TYLER OR-
DOCTORS. AND A KANSEN IF YOU
LIKE TO COME IN THIS WELL. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY SO THE
FEE INCREASE IS SIMPLY A PART OF
THE NORMAL PROGRESSION OF HOW
THINGS ARE AT. ON CAMPUS WILL TO
EXPANDING THE PROGRAM V. THE
LIMIT THAT'S BEING DISCUSSED
HERE 25% LIMIT INCREASED FOR
FROM HERE TO HERE. IS REALLY
ONLY PART OF THE PICTURE THE
STATE FUNDS THAT GO IN AND
SUPPORT THE PROGRAM A CONSTANT
FROM YEAR TO YEAR IF YOU BREAK
IT DOWN INTO OUR REVENUE
INCREASE FROM YEAR TO YEAR WITH
THIS FIVE PERCENT. MAXIMUM IT
ACTUALLY TRANSLATE TO A 3%
MAXIMUM WHICH IS THE STANDARD.
AT THE UNIVERSITY FOR GRANTS
THAT WE COULD CALCULATE INTO
MULTI YEAR GRANTS FROM YEAR TO
YEAR INCREASE IN IN THE AMOUNT
OF DOLLARS THAT- THAT IS
EXPECTED TO BE SPENT ON THE
PROGRAM. I HAD SO- I DON'T
DISPUTE ANY ISSUE THAT THE COST
TO GO UP I'M JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHY- WE WOULD WANT TO
SPEAK INTO THE SPACE OF ABOUT
HOW MUCH WHEN THIS IS A REGION
CHOICE. AND THIS IS THE
UNIVERSITY CHOICE AND THEIR
BUDGET REQUESTS COME TO US EACH
YEAR. TO FIND A VARIETY OF
PROGRAMS THIS ONE. HAZARD WOULD
BE INCLUDED IN THAT WHY WHY WHY
IS IT BEING PULLED OUT IN THIS
WAY. AND GIVEN OUR FINANCIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES IN THE STATE IT'S
AN UNCOMFORTABLE ISSUE FOR ME TO
WANT TO RAISE TUITION AND FEES
WE WERE EVEN A WORTHY PROGRAM
LIKE THIS. WHEN THIS REALLY IS A
CHOICE THE REGION'S CONNECTS SO
AGAIN I GO BACK TO THE
JURISDICTIONAL ISSUE. WHY SHOULD
WE IN THE LEGISLATURE. THE
SETTING AYE AYE AND AMOUNTS IN
THIS BILL THIS WHERE. THE BILL
THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO GET
OUT HERE. DO YOU WANT YOUR LIKE
YES IF I MAY SAY MEDIA NO SENT
GLAZER AYE APPRECIATE THAT CON-
YOU'RE YOU'RE RIGHT. IS NOT BEEN
A PRIORITY FOR THE UC AND IN
PARTICULAR FOR THIS YEAR IN
TERMS OF THE REGION'S ASK- BUT I
THINK IN GENERAL YOU KNOW WE BE
OPEN TO HAVING CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THAT IN THE FUTURE- THIS
IS LARGELY JUST. A PRIORITY OF
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT. IF
COST TO INCREASE AND WHEN THEY
DO INCREASE IN THE FUTURE. I
WOULD NOTE THAT THERE IS A
LITTLE BIT OF SAVINGS FROM COVE
IN THE LAST TWO YEARS WOULD HAVE
BEEN GREAT AND CAN BE. PUT
TOWARDS MORE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE AND CAN. HELP ME OUT
HERE. BUT THE SAME TIME- THE
ABILITY TO INCREASE IT 25% EACH
YEAR- THAT'S THE THIRTY WERE
LOOKING FOR BUT I THINK EVERYONE
HAVE A DIFFERENT CONVERSATION
ABOUT. THE FUNDING PRIORITIES
I'D BE HAPPY TO. TO TALK ABOUT
IF I COULD JUST INTERJECT YET
THEN AND I WANT TO INTERJECT TO
SAY THAT THE TUITION AMOUNT IS
ALREADY IN STATUTE. SO THIS
ISN'T CHANGING WHAT'S IN STATUTE
IF THAT HELPS YOU AT ALL. RIGHT
BUT YOU'RE LEYVA WHAT I'M TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND IS THAT THIS BILL
WAS SILENT ON TUITION. OTHER
REGIONS WITHOUT EVERYTHING IN
THEIR POWER TO MAKE A CHOICE
ABOUT HOW THEY FUND THE PROGRAM
WITH THEIR REQUIRES FEE
INCREASES ARE TUITION INCREASES.
AS IS. THE CASE FOR. ALL
UNDERGRADUATE AND GRADUATE
EDUCATION IN THE SYSTEM SO WHY
DO WE AS THE LEGISLATURE NEEDED.
TO EVEN PUT THESE PARAMETERS NOT
WHY IS THAT PART OF THIS BILL
WHY IS IT NECESSARY I GUESS IF
IT DIFFERENTLY. I WANT TO
SUPPORT EXPANDING AND IN THIS
PROGRAM BUT- BUT WHYDO WE HAVE
TO SPEAK PLAZA TO SPEAK TO THIS
ISSUE OF TUITION AND FEES. OKAY
AND I'M GONNA LET CENTER MEN
ANSWER AND THEN I'M GONNA GO TO
YOU SENATOR DOLLY AND PERHAPS
TYLER CAN EXPAND ON THIS BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING OF PROGRAM. IS
THAT THIS IS. THIS PARTICULAR.
METHOD OF- PROVIDING
AUTHORIZATION RIKSBANK TUITION.
IS CONSISTENT WITH HOW THE
PROGRAM HAS BEEN FUNDED AND PASS
AND- AS I THINK EITHER ALLUDED
TO THIS IS NOT ACTUALLY. LISTED
IS NOT A PRIORITY FOR THE UC
REGENTS- AND I DON'T KNOW WHY
THAT IS I DON'T KNOW. SO THIS IF
WE WANT TO DO THIS OURSELVES-
YOU KNOW THAT THIS IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT. CAN MATCH UP
WITH EXPECTED INCREASES OR
POTENTIAL INCREASES IN COSTS AND
INFLATION- THIS THIS IS GOING TO
NOW WE COULD HAVE SCOTIAN. POSE
HOC ABOUT WITH WE WANT TO CHANGE
THE FUNDING- AND TAKE MORE CAN.
AND I BE HAPPY TO HAVE THAT
KIND. WE YOU AND YOUR STAFF- BUT
BUT AT THIS POINT TIME THIS IS.
I GUESS THIS IS THE STATUS QUO
STAYING THE COURSE AS I
UNDERSTAND IT BUT TYLER IS THAT.
CORRECT ARTICULATION. YEAH I
MEAN SO YOU KNOW THIS BILL IS
ENTIRELY CONSISTENT WITH THE
PREVIOUS VERSION. EIGHTY SIX ONE
SIX THAT WENT TO THE LEGISLATURE
WHICH ESSENTIALLY JUST ASK FOR
THE SAME. ALLOWABLE 5% IN THE
SAME FIVE YEAR. REAUTHORIZATION
ARE FOCUSED. WORST IS ON THE
SUNSET EXTENSION GIVEN THAT
BECAUSE THE LEGISLATURE CREATED
THE PROGRAM. WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CONTINUE TO COME BACK TO
YOU AND- HAVE THE CHANCE TO HAVE
THIS CONVERSATION SO WE
APPRECIATE THAT- BUT AT THIS
POINT WE JUST LEAVE IT AT FIVE
YEAR EXTENSION. SO IT'S
UPDATING. THE LANGUAGE RATHER
THAN RE WRITING THE LANGUAGE. SO
IT'S ALREADY BEEN DONE BEFORE
THIS IS AN EXTENSION OF THE
PROGRAM- I UNDERSTAND THAT AND I
THINK THAT I LOOK AT I WAS IN
AROUND TWENTY YEARS AGO OR
WHATEVER WAS ESTABLISHED BUT- MY
GUESS IS THAT. THROUGH
LEADERSHIP IN THE LEGISLATURE.
AND THE DESIRE TO ADVANCE A
PROGRAM LIKE THIS. THAT WE-
PASSED A LOT OF DUE TO. THE TO
THE REGIONS THIS MAY NOT BE A
PRIORITY TO YOU BUT IT'S A
PRIORITY TO US. SO IT IS A
LITTLE CURIOUS AT THIS POINT IN
TIME IT'S THAT YOU CAN CREDIBLY
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM. WHY WE HAVE
TO DO THAT ANYMORE I MEAN I. YOU
TALK ABOUT A FIVE YEAR EXTENSION
I RATHER ELIMINATE- THE AND THE
US SUNSET ON IT THE PROGRAM
STAYS IN EFFECT FOREVER. BUT I
WHAT'S BAFFLING TO ME IS THAT
THIS IS A REALLY A WORKAROUND OF
OUR BUDGET PROCESS I'M
INCREDIBLY SUPPORTIVE OF OUR- OF
OUR UC EDUCATION I THINK W
OUGHT TO GIVE THEM A LOT MORE
MONEY THAN THEY'VE BEEN GETTING.
AND THEY GET TO SET THE
PRIORITIES IF THIS IS A SELF
SUSTAINING PROGRAM WHICH I THINK
THE CLAIM IS THAT IT IS. WHY
WOULD THE REGION'S EVER OBJECT.
TO THAT- TO CONTINUING THAT IN
THIS FORM OR WHATEVER FORM OF
THEIR WISDOM AND IT'S AGAIN. WHY
SB AS A LEGISLATOR VOTING FOR A
TUITION INCREASE AT THIS POINT
IN TIME IS THE UNCOMFORTABLE
PART OF WHAT IT. WHAT IT IS A
WONDERFUL PROGRAM THAT'S ALL I
WANTED TO TRY TO CLARIFY. THANK
YOU CENTER CLOSER INTENDED
DOLLAR FORGET YOUR DID HAVE A
CENTER PAM BEFORE YOU SORRY. GO
AHEAD CENTER PAM. THANK YOU SO
FIRST OF ALL OF THE STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE PROGRAM AND OF
THE BILL. I GUESS- FROM HEARING
FROM SAN GLAZER IS THAT ALTHOUGH
IT'S BEEN PASSED THE RATIONS OF
THE BILL WHY EVEN BOTHER PUTTING
IT TUITION. AMOUNT IN THERE
RIGHT IT IS IT'S- LOOK AT THE
REGIONS DO THAT AND MAKE A
COMMITMENT THAT- IS IT'S-
PRESENTED BY THE- WITNESSES
SUPPORT AND THAT- THAT THERE'S A
COMMITMENT TO PROVIDING
FINANCIAL AID SO THAT. FINANCIAL
YELTSIN THAT SO THAT- NEEDS A
DATE SO THAT IT'S- NOT A NATION
ISN'T. BASED ON- ISN'T AFFECTED%
BY NEED RIGHT SO THAT ALL ALL.
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS WHO QUALIFY
WOULD HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
IN THE PROGRAM AND JUST NOT GET
INTO THE HOW MUCH. YOU'RE
CHARGING IT SAID AROUND LESS L.
AS LONG AS THERE'S FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE. TO INSURE THAT AT.
ALL STUDENTS REGARD. OF OTHER.
INCOME HOUSEHOLD INCOME OR A-
TO. PRODUCE AND BE SUPPORTED. SO
THE PERHAPS YOU CAN FIGURE OUT
HOW TO THAT THIS BUT I DIGITAL
TO SAY THAT I'M REALLY SUPPORT-
APPRECIATE FACT THAT WE HAVE SO
MANY- AEROSPACE ENGINEERS-
MECHANICAL ENGINEERS INVOLVED
BECAUSE MY FATHER WAS ALSO A
MECHANICAL ENGINEER HER SPACE
ENGINEER. SO SO WITH THAT-
ACTUALLY I WOULD TO THE MOVE THE
BILL AND ACTUALLY ASK THE COULD
BE A CO AUTHOR MOVING FORWARD
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER PANTS
CENTER DOLLY. THANK YOU I LOOK.
WE ALL SUPPORTED BUT I THINK
THIS IS- THE PRESIDENT SETTING
THIS KIND F A WORK AROUND OUR
BUDGET PROCESS THAT'S WHAT I.
HEAR THE SENATOR BRING UP AND I
THINK THAT IT'S UNFORTUNATE
THAT- THIS COULD THIS COULD
HAPPEN IN OTHER BILLS AND WE'RE
ACTUALLY. GOING TO BE RAISING
TUITION AT A TIME WHEN WE SHOULD
JUST BE PAYING FOR IT. OUT OF
OUR BUDGET SO I THINK THAT- YOU
MIGHT WANNA DRESSES I THINK THIS
IS I THINK WE COULD DO THIS WE
CAN TAKEA MINUTE TO THIS BILL
IT WOULD BE. VERY HELPFUL I
THINK TO JUST SEND IT TO THE
REGULAR PROCESS AND THAT WAY WE
WOULD BE RAISING TUITION. JUST
PAY FOR IT OUT OF THE- REGULAR
BUDGET PROCESS. VERY GOOD THANK
YOU I WILL LET YOU- AND THE
AUTHOR DISCUSS FUTURE
AMENDMENTS- WE HAVE THE BILL
BEFORE US NOW WHICH WE WILL
VOTING ON. BUT BEFORE THAT
THERE'S NO CHOI BOGUE AND CENTER
CORTESE GO HEAD CENTER CHOI
BOGUE. I JUST I WITHOUT BEING
REDUNDANT I JUST WANNA. SAY THAT
ACTUALLY SUPPORT- THE COMMENTS
MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE SARAH
CENTER GLAZERS THAT ARE DOLLY. I
ALSO BELIEVE IN THE PROGRAM AND
I THINK IT'S A WONDERFUL PROGRAM
AND IT SHOULD BE. CONTINUING
WOULD LOVE TO SEE THE SUNSET
PERIOD JUST BE REMOVED I'M NOT
SURE WHY IT'S THERE- BEING THAT.
IT IT. HAS INCREDIBLE MERIT AND
IS SO MUCH NEEDED TODAY'S TIME
SO. I'M NOT SURE THAT COULD ALSO
BE AN AMENDMENT ON THAT END. IF
THAT COULD JUST BE. COMPLETELY
REMOVED BUT I ALSO BELIEVE THAT
WE NEED TO DO WHAT IT IS. RIGHT
AND AT THIS TIME. THE HARDEST
PART FOR ME FOR THIS BILL RIGHT
NOW IS THAT IT. IS TALKS ABOUT
INCREASING FEES AND AT THE TIME
OF WERE HAVING A SURPLUS THAT WE
DO HAVE. AN UNDERSTANDING OF
FINANCIAL- IMITATIONS OUR
FAMILIES- IN OUR STUDENTS HAVE.
I AM I'M KIND OF GREATLY
CONCERNED WITH THAT AND ALSO I
JUST WANTED TO KNOW THAT IF I
UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY. IT SAYS
HERE THAT- IN TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN ELIGIBLE IN STATE
STUDENTS PAID THIRTY NINE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO FOR THE
SUMMER PROGRAM WITH ONLY ELEVEN
PARTICIPANTS RECEIVING ANY
FINANCIAL AID. THIS IS A
REDUCTION FROM THE TWO SUMMER
TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN WERE
NEARLY 22% OF PARTICIPANTS
RECEIVED FINANCIAL AID IS THERE.
PLEASE SO IF YOU IT'S 11% BUT
NOT JUST ELEVEN TO ELEVEN I'M
SORRY THAT'S WHAT I'M AT 11% I
APOLOGIZE YES WITH IT ONLY 11%
OF PARTICIPANTS RECEIVING
FINANCIAL AID- A REDUCTION FROM
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WITH NEARLY
2240% OF OUR PARTICIPANTS
RECEIVING FINANCIAL AID WHY SUCH
A REDUCTION. WOULD COME FROM THE
APPLICANT POOL OF WE HAVE AGREAT EFFORT IN OUTREACH AND
TRYING TO GET AS MANY A STUDENT
FROM CALIFORNIA TO COME INTO THE
PROGRAM AS I SAID THE ADMISSIONS
PROCESS IS NEED BLIND AND THE
FINANCIAL AID AWARDS ARE BASED
ONLY AND SOLELY UPON FINANCIAL
NEED SO THIS IS WHAT WE WHAT
COMES TO MY OFFICE FROM THE
CAMPUSES WERE ADMITTING TO
STUDENTS. WHO DO NOT KNOW WHICH
STUDENT IS IN FINANCIAL NEED-
IT'S SIMPLY BASED ON HOW THEY
FIT INTO THE CLUSTERS FOR THIS
THESE ARE NOT MEMBERS THAT WE
TRY TO DESIGN BEFORE THE NUMBERS
TO COME OUT OF IT SO IT'S SIMPLY
THE AMOUNT OF ADMITTED. STUDENTS
INTO THE PROGRAM. THE HAS THAT
STATISTICS SO WE AWARD FINANCIAL
NEED A FINANCIAL AID. RICK
REGARDLESS OF HOW MANY IT IS- WE
SIMPLY USE THAT WILL BREAK SO IT
TURNED OUT THAT THAT THE YEAR
THAT WAS A LOW NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WHO NEEDED FOR NEED A
PROFESSIONAL OKAY THE STATE WE
DON'T FIND ACTUALLY TRIED TO
HAVE A TARGET AMOUNT DURING THE-
FIFTH PERFECT THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION THANK YOU SENATOR
CHOI BOGUE. CENTER CORTESE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU'RE A
GOOD EIGHT EIGHT DO HAVE JUST
COME OF A TECH QUESTION BUT I
WANT TO. AGREE WITH THE GENERAL
. FRIEND OF THE COMMENTS ON THE
SUNSET I THINK THIS IS AN
OUTSIDE ORGANIZATION. NON
GOVERNMENTAL RBC. THERE BE SOME
DESIRE TO DO THAT- IN IT WE HAVE
WHAT I WOULD DESCRIBE AS MASSIVE
AMOUNTS OF THESE KIND OF
PROGRAMS THAT ARE STOOD UP BY
NON GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES- IN
SILICON VALLEY BUT- BUT THAT'S
SAID- THE TECHNICAL QUESTION I
HAVE IS IN IN. THE SECOND PART
OF- THE DISCUSSION HERE IN MY
PACKET IT TALKS ABOUT SITTING
FEE UP TO. FORTY EIGHT HUNDRED
TEN DOLLARS PER SESSION- THAT
CORRESPONDS TO ACTUAL PROGRAM
COSTS WHICH- TO ME SOUNDS LIKE
JUST COST RECOVERY IN MY
TECHNICAL QUESTION IS. THIS THIS
IS UC- BROWN BY COST RECOVERY-
PRINCIPLES ON FEES- LIKE. A
GOVERNMENT. AGENCIES ARE WE NEED
YOU CAN'T EXCEED COST RECOVERY
BUT WITHOUT THAT BECOMING A
ATTACKS BASICALLY ALLOWED
ALLOWED TAYLOR TO ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS AS WE CAN I THINK I
DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO
QUESTION NO IT'S COMING BEFORE
I'M HAPPY TO GET THE ANSWER AND
THEN GIVE IT BACK TO YOUR OFFICE
ONCE I GET IT- BUT I DON'T HAVE
ON THE TOP OF MY HEAD. YEAH IF
YOU COULD BE IMPORTANT I MEAN
I'M CURIOUS ABOUT IT ANYWAY THE
PROBABLY. WOULD APPLY TO. USER
LEGISLATION THAT LOOKING AT IT
AT SOME LEVEL- BUT ALSO. IT'S IF
IT'S- IF ALREADY HAVE COST
RECOVERY. YOU KNOW LIMITS AND
CAPABILITIES ON OUR OWN- THEN
AGAIN YOU KNOW THIS WHY WHY EVEN
BOTHER PRESCRIBING TO THE BILL
OTHER THAN TO JUST SAY THAT- IF
ANYTHING THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT
WOULD BE THAT YOU WOULD MAKE
SEEK COST RECOVERY BUT I HINK
THAT'S REDUNDANT. I JUST I JUST
WANT TO MENTION THAT IT. IT MAY
JUST IN THE ENTIRE NEED FOR ANY
OF THAT KIND OF LANGUAGE THANK
YOU AND I DO INTEND. B. AND I
BOTH OF THE BILL SAID I THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING REPORT. THANK
YOU CENTER CORTE CENTER BEFORE I
GET YOU FOR YOUR- YOUR CLOTHES.
I WOULD JUST SAY- THANK YOU FOR
THE ROBUST DISCUSSION MEMBERS
AND THE I AM SUPPORTING THE BILL
FULLY. THIS IS A SUNSET
EXTENSION IT HAS BEEN DONE FOUR
TIMES BEFORE SO THIS IS NOT NEW-
MY CONCERN IS THAT WE DON'T WANT
TO HARM. A CLEARLY SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM. I WOULD ASK FOLKS THIS
IS THE FIRST POLICY COMMITTEE.
AND IF THERE ARE CONCERNS AND
AMENDMENTS THAT FOLKS ARE
LOOKING FOR. I WOULD SUGGEST
THAT WE GET IT OUT OF COMMITTEE
TODAY AND THEN YOU WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR. TO MAKE SURE ANY OF
THOSE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCERNED
YOU HAVE A WORK OUT WITH HIM.
CENTERMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I THANK YOU MANAGER AND
THANK YOU FOR THOSE COMMENTS I
WOULD AGREE WITH THEM AND JUST
POINT OUT YOU KNOW WE ARE HAPPY
TO CONSIDER YOU KNOW. THE ENDING
IS A SENSE THAT WE'RE HAPPY TO
CONSIDER MAKING THIS PROGRAM
PERMANENT- I THINK RIGHT NOW THE
GOAL IS TO. AND EXTENDING THIS
BUT- SHOULD THERE BE THE
APPETITE WITHIN THE BODY HERE TO
DO SOMETHING MORE AMBITIOUS- WE
RECENTLY OPENED THAT I THINK WE
ALL SHARE THE SENTIMENT HERE
THAT- THIS IS A PROGRAM WORTH
DOING- IT HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL.
AND IT HAS PROMOTED NOT ONLY
GENDER EQUITY BYA LOT OF RACIAL
EQUITY WHICH I DIDN'T MENTION AS
WELL AND THAT'S GONNA BE
IMPORTANT FOR THE FUTURE
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. FOR YOUR TIME AND
I ASKED RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTERMAN.
CENTER PANDERED TO MOVE THE BILL
VERY GOOD MENTAL CONSULTANT THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR PAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I AM
NUMBER FIVE S. B. TWELVE NINETY
NINE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE AMENDED. LEYVA AYE.
LEYVA AYE OTOBO. AYE WHICH
OBADIAH COURTESY I. CORTES THE
AYE DALY. GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN HI
CAN I ALL RIGHT WE WILL LEAVE
THAT ON CALL FOR OUR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU SENATOR MAN
ALL RIGHT WE ARE MOVING TO OUR
FINAL BILL CENTER PAN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO GO THANK YOU THAT WILL
BE ITEM NUMBER SIX SB NINE NINE
SEVEN BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY SENATOR PAM. WE HAVE A NEW
ROOM WE'RE ALL GETTING USED TO
IT. ALL GOOD.
THANKS JOHN YES IT WAS ON ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
SENATORS- I AM PLEASED PERCENT
SB NINE NINE SEVEN THE BILL THAT
WILL AMPLIFY STUDENT VOICES AND
- BUDGET DISCUSSIONS. SB NINE
NINE SEVEN STRENGTHENS STUDENT
PARTICIPATION IN CONVERSATIONS
REGARDING THE- LOCAL CONTROL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLANS. AND IS
KNOWN AS EL CAP AND- PROVIDES
LIAISE WITH TWO OPTIONS FOR
IMPLEMENTATION. THE FIRST WOULD
ADD TO STUDENT NUMBERS TO ANY
PARENT ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT
REVIEWS THE L. CAP. OR THE
SECOND OPTION WOULD ALLOW THE
CREATION OF A STUDENT ADVISORY
COMMITTEE TO REVIEW THE L. CAP.
YOU'LL CAP IS A POWERFUL
PLANNING TOOL THAT HELPS
DISTRICTS VALLEY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION OUTLINED GOALS ACTION
SERVICES AND EXPENDITURES. IN
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES EACH
LOCATELLI A TO HAVE A PARENT
ADVISORY COMMITTEE THE PROVIDES
INPUT TO THE AQAP. L. STILL
INPUT IS TYPICALLY SOLICITED
THROUGH MEANS OF GENERAL
CONSOLATION THEY JUST SURVEYS
AND FORMS. THE WAKE OF THE
ONGOING PANDEMIC MOST OF THE
PRESSING IT AT THE MOST PRESSING
EDUCATIONAL CHALLENGES SUCH AS
LEARNING LOS COLLAPSES IN THE
DIVISION CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM
MENTAL HEALTH CRISES AND MORE.
BECOMING INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT
TO ADDRESS. BUT THERE'S A LACK
OF STUDENT REPRESENTATION ON
BEST EL CAPIT BY THREE
COMMITTEES HOW CAN WE MOST THAT
THE EFFECTIVELY IDENTIFY AND
ADDRESS THE MOST PRESSING
CHALLENGES THEIR STUDENTS FACE.
IS ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL THAT%
ELLIE AS ALLOW STUDENTS DIRECTLY
IN THE L. CAP PROCESS. IN ORDER
TO ADAPT PRIORITIES AND ENSURE
THAT BUDGETS REFLECT IMMEDIATE
CONCERNS OF STUDENTS THIS BILL
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT THERE'S NO
SUBSTITUTE FOR STUDENT VOICES IN
EDUCATION POLICY OR GIVE
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. A SEAT AT
THE TABLE. SB NINE SEVEN JOYCE
FROM GENERATION UP THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT BOARD THAT
NUMBER ASSOCIATION AND
CALIFORNIANS FOR JUSTICE THERE'S
NO. FORMAL REGISTERED OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL AND I'M
PLEASED TO HAVE TWO WITNESSES
AND PORT- LAYO CORDEAUX CLARK
FROM CHEN UP AND FORMER L. CAPS-
NUMBER IN DR MICHAEL KERR STUFF
FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION AND A KEY ARCHITECT.
OF THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA THANK YOU. TERRIFIC
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO WE WILL
ALL GO TO OUR MINER MODERATOR
WILL GO TO OUR FIRST LEAD
WITNESS WHICH IS. LEO CORSO
CLARK AND YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
MISTER CLARK. HELLO YOU'LL HEAR
ME WE SURE CAN. EXCELLENT
MORNING CHAIRWOMAN LEYBURN
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
LEVEL COURSE OF CLARK AND I'M
THE FORMER STUDENT BOARD MEMBER
OF ALBANY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THE EAST BAY A
STUDENT ADVOCATE WITH JENNA I
WAS ALSO THE FIRST EVER STUDENT
NUMBER OF ALBANY UNIFIED HEALTH
HAVE ADVISORY COMMITTEE BUT I
HELD FOR THREE YEARS UNTIL I
GRADUATED WHEN I ATTENDED MY
FIRST OKAY MEETING I'LL ADMIT I
FELT A BIT OUT OF PLACE. I WAS
DAUNTED BY UNFAMILIAR TERMS LIKE
UNDUPLICATED PUPILS AND I
AUTOMATICALLY ASSUMED MY INPUT
TO BE LESS VALUABLE THE
EXPERTISE OF SOME OF THE MORE
EXPERIENCE THE BILL FROM THE
COMMITTEE HOWEVER WHEN IT WAS MY
FIRST TURN TO GIVE INPUT ON
ALBANY'S DISTRICT GOALS AND
PRIORITIES I WAS SHOCKED TO SEE
THE AMAZEMENT OF THE ADULT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THE SURE
THE MOST BASIC OF STUDENT
CONCERNS PARENTS TEACHERS
ADMINISTRATORS AND SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS NONE HAD ANY LEVEL OF
FAMILIARITY WITH ISSUES THAT
WERE UNIVERSALLY KNOWN TO THE
STUDENT BODY. IT WAS THEN THAT I
REALIZED THAT EVEN WITH NO PRIOR
EXPERIENCE AT ALL MY VOICE AND
INPUT HAD A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
ON A HELICOPTER I BELIEVE THAT
STUDENT INPUT IS THE SOLUTION TO
CALIFORNIA'S MOST PRESSING
ISSUES IN EDUCATION IF YOU'RE
DROPPING CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM ASK
STUDENTS THE REASON BEING IS
CLASS YOU'RE COMBATING THE
RACIAL ACHIEVEMENT GAP AFLAC IN
HISPANIC STUDENTS WHAT RESOURCES
WE BELIEVE WE NEED TO SUCCEED
THE STUDENT PERSPECTIVE IS MORE
THAN JUST ONE MORE VOICE IN THE
ROOM IT INSIGHT ON EVERY ASPECT
OF THE SCHOOL EXPERIENCE BEYOND
TEST SCORES AND ATTENDANCE RATE.
I THINK I CAN NOT BE MEASURED
WITH NUMBERS AND CANNOT BE
SUBSTITUTED BY INPUT FROM ADULTS
WHO ARE TOO FAR REMOVED FROM THE
CLASSROOM EXPERIENCE AT THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS SHOWN US
THE ISSUES THAT SCHOOL DIDN'T
SPACE ARE CONSTANTLY AND RAPIDLY
CHANGING IN ORDER FOR ELLIE IS
TO ENSURE THAT THEIR PRIORITIES
TRULY REFLECTED IN NEED
SIMPLICES MUST BE CENTERED IN
THESE CRITICAL CONVERSATIONS AND
THAT STARTS WITH MEANINGFUL ST
REPRESENTATION IN THE L. CAP
PROFIT. ON BEHALF OF CHEN UP
INSTANCE FROM ACROSS CALIFORNIA
I URGE THIS COMMITTEE TO VOTE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE NINE SEVEN
THANK YOU TERRIFIC THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO
TO ATTACK DR MICHAEL KIRST-
MISTER KIRSTY PROCEED. WHEN
YOU'RE READY YOU ALSO TWO
MINUTES. HI MICHAEL. PROFESSOR
EMERITUS IS STAN YOU. AND THE
LAW. UP FOR. PRESS OF THE CAL.
STATE BOARD OF A- I'VE WORKED
ONE OF THE- THE- LOCAL CAN.
FUNDING FORMULA IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN. WE HAVE OUR RIGHTS
SINCE TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
ABOUT HOW ATTRACTIVE AN
IMPORTANT STUDENT VOICES ARE- IN
ORDER TO CATION POLICY BUT
PARTICULARLY I THINK IN THE
LOCAL CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY-
THE PLAN. THIS PLAN- THE BRING
STUDENTS CLOSER TO THE BUDGETS
AND AS YOU KNOW BUDGETS ARE
POLICY AND STUDENTS HAVE NOT
REALLY BEEN ABLE TO I THINK IT
INTO THE MIDDLE OF THE BUDGET
PROCESS AND THE IMPORTANT PARTS
OF IT. SO THIS WOULD BE AN
IMPORTANT- ACTIVATION TO STUDENT
VOICE AND- AND HELPING PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THEIR NEEDS. MOREOVER
TODAY HELLO THE L. CAP HAS-
CLEARLY INDICATIONS OF THE
CHANGES FROM PRIOR BUDGETS IT
SETS NEW PRIORITIES FOR OVER A
THREE YEAR TERM- SO- ROOM FIVE
STUDENTS AND A LONGER- YOU OF
POLICY THAT THEY DO NOT DO NOT
HAVE NOW. I THINK TOO MANY
STUDENTS THINK THEY'RE JUST BY
PASSING A LOT OF THINGS HAPPEN
BUT AS YOU WELL KNOW. IT TAKES
FUNDING OFTEN. BRING THE ABOUT
AND THEY WILL BETTER ON IT- THE
ONLY AREA. THAT THAT YOU TAKE A
LOOK AT IT IS TO HEAR MIDDLE
SCHOOL AND- I'M NOT HELD TO THE
THINK ABOUT LOOKS NOW YOU MIGHT
WANT TO THINK ABOUT THAT A MORE-
DEPT. AND THEN CALL OUT THIS IS
A FIVE THING FOR AND- OUR PATH
AND I SUPPORT THE- THANK DR
KERR'S. ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO
ANYONE WHO'S IN SUPPORT HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED SEEING
NO ONE. MADAME MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANYONE ON THE LINE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE NINE SEVEN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OF A FIFTY NINE
NINETY SEVEN. YOU MAY PRESS. ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE NINE SEVEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
. OUR FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM
LINE NINETEEN. MY NINETEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD MORNING KAREN MEANING THAT
THERE THAT THE AND LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINETY
SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS RAY OF THE AREA I AM A
JUNIOR ARE OVER SAID STEM
ACADEMY AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
CAMPAIGNS AT GENERATION AND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB NINE NINE
SEVEN. THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE NINE SEVEN. THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR I WE HAVE NO LEAD
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL IS THERE
ANYONE IN TWENTY ONE HUNDRED WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO ONE ABOUT A MODERATOR
WILL GO BACK TO YOU AND SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE. WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB NINE
NINE SEVEN ON THE PHONE LINES.
THANK YOU MDAM CHAIR AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION SB NINE
NINETY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS. ONE
AND ZERO AT THE TIME. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB. NINE NINE
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND
THEN THERE. WE HAVE NO COMMENT
TO QUEUE AT THIS TIME GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE BILL'S
BEEN MOVED BY CENTER DOLLY WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SENATOR PAM. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I THANK
YOU VERY GOOD THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR DOLLY. MN
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX S. B. NINE
NINE SEVEN THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE OCHO ABODE I
BUT CHAU ABOVE AYE COURTESY AYE
FERTILITY AYE DALY. SALLY I
GLAZER. GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE PAN ALL RIGHT. HI
SEVEN ALL RIGHT THAT BILLS OUT
SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU CENTER PAN.
ALL RIGHT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE ARE NOW GOING TO GO TO
OUR BILLS THAT ARE ON CALL. WE
WILL START WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. CONSENT CHAIR VOTING
ON A VICE CHAIR HAS NOT VOTED. I
WOULD PROVOKE AYE. MCGUIRE
ACQUIRE I CAN I CAN I SEVEN ZERO
FIGURE THAT OUT CONSENT HOLDERS
ARE DONE AND OUT SEVEN ZERO.
NEXT WE WILL GO TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE. WHILE THE ABSENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE SB
NINE FORTY ONE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATION.
SHARES VOTED ARI FLEISCHER'S
VOTED AYE MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE
THAT BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO PLEASE OF SORRY
THAT'S ON CONSENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE S. B. THIRTEEN ZERO TWO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR IS VOTED
ON BY VICE CHAIR HAS VOTED AYE
REQUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE SEVEN ZERO
VERY GOOD THAT BILLS OUT SEVEN
ZERO FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
PLEASE CALL AT THAT IS CONSENT
TO SORRY FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
PLEASE CALL. THE ABSENT MEMBERS
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE S. B.
TWELVE NINETY NINE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE AMENDED.
SHARES VOTED OFF BY VICE CHAIRS. VOTED ON BY DELHI. GLAZER
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE THE BILLS
OUT BY ZERO. WILL MOVE ON THE I
THINK FOOT SUBPHYLUM SIX WE'RE
GOOD ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD THANK
YOU EVERYONE. I WANT TO THANK
ALL OF THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIMONY IS TESTIFIED TODAY.
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO
US WE WANTED THAT TO INCLUDE
YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. THANK YOU AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATORY
TO THE PATIENT THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA AND THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. IS NOW
ADJOURNED. THANKS EVERYBODY.